[Musique]
rv l'attestation dérogatoire de sortie
aux apéros skype on comprend un mot sur
12 re aux applaudissements à 20h au pain
maison le vin qui ressemble à rien re à
ceux qui s'enfuient dans la maison de
campagne
re confinement la première vague a été
celle de l'improvisation ni masque ni
jaïn raulic ni blouse pénurie de
médicaments injonctions contradictoires
à répétition du gouvernement la seconde
vague et celle de l'impréparation lequel
a tweeté tout à leur confinement au
risque de pénurie alimentaire je
confirme les consommateurs depuis une
semaine se jette à nouveau sur les
pattes un sens 30% et le et le papier
toilette plus d'un pour cent
voilà on veut juste mangé des pâtes elle
aux toilettes pas de panique il y a du
stock partout ne rejoue pas mars 2020
là je déroge que emmanuel macron arrête
ça et vendit moi je vais ouvrir tous mes
restaurants parce que je recevoir un sms
de mai gérants libres ils disent on va
fermer
on coule donc voilà donc je vais
demander à tous mes joueurs en libre
d'ouvrir et je demande à toute la france
d'ouvrir
donc voilà ouvrons franchement là qu'est
ce qui va se passer
il va se passer que les gens ont volé
chez eux ils vont faire des soirées ils
vont faire n'importe quoi donc une moi
je vais ouvrir
j'ai pas besoin des deux mois les aides
je m'en fous moi les aides c'est terminé
je vais fermer
donc je vais ouvrir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la bamboche c'est terminé
kim kardashian voulait fêter ses 40 ans
avec ses proches
et c'est exactement ce qu'elle a fait à
tahiti la star de téléréalité a affrété
un avion privé pour l'occasion une fête
avec des dizaines de convives sans
masque ni gestes barrières des tests ont
été faits affirme l'américaine sur les
réseaux sociaux
mais pour beaucoup d'internautes
organiser un tel événement en pleine
crise sanitaire et économique est
indécente des critiques qui n'empêche
pas sa publication instagram de déplacer
les 5 millions de mention j'aime le g et
qualifie le personnes au comportement
ridicule grotesque il t'inquiète le
monde de demain
ouais ouais m'inquiète servat je vis
bien j'ai la chance d'être avec des gens
qui ne font qu'y fait j'ai la chance
d'aimer ce que je fais j'ai la chance
d'avoir des gosses qui sont plutôt bien
sa bosse à l'école sa vie on n'a pas
trop d'inquiétude à se faire à leur
sujet et pourtant ouais il inquiète
commandes bondissent en guadeloupe
mais on est tellement bloquée et fine et
que c'était que j'ai l'impression de
voyager
ce n'est peut-être pas la manière la
plus confortable pour apprendre mais
c'est mieux que rien ces jeunes
napolitains suivent des cours
malgré la fermeture de leur école pour
leurs institutrices il était important
qu'il continue à apprendre
les enfants ne comprenais pas pourquoi
il ne pouvait plus retourner à l'école
alors je me suis dit on va s'organiser
on va se retrouver en respectant les
consignes de sécurité et se renier à
l'extérieur dans des endroits où de
toute façon les enfants passent tous les
jours
j'étais en maternelle pendant des années
alors n'aurait pas et je leur faisais
pas être chez chantal goya storeway
plutôt quoi dazhou
what pnl nombreux collages ou là les
[ __ ] à connaître de là à dire que
naisse entre les enfants et douze lequel
devrait aller à l'école pour apprendre
alors on va continuer de jouer entre
encana ligaments croisés du genou
propose en fait les digues et amour du
cerveau qui il faut c'est un peu qui
le petit
hélas ces mots assez marrant lâche at
elle dit je ne sais pas ce que vous vous
pensez des humains mais moi j'ai fini
par les trouver touchants ils ont des
comportements tellement irrationnelle et
on sent que derrière tout ça vous vous
moquez de nous en général vous nous
trouvez irrationnel où les hommes il
faut se mettre à la place de l'animal
qui nous regardaient objectivement dans
nos comportements nous sommes quand même
un peu bizarre c'est une boutique au
japon tout ce qu'il ya de plus normal du
sol jusqu'au plafond
ah non là le gérant installer des dalles
de verre pour que ces chats puisse
observer la boutique toute la journée
il faut dire que ces félins sont très
dissipée alors ça les occupe quelques
photos publiées sur twitter
et voilà que le magasin a gagné en
popularité il suffit de regarder
l'actualité il suffit de même
actuellement histoire de kobe d'imagés
un chat qui voit tous les gens qui se
mettent à mettre ce masque comment il
interprète pour nous ç'a l'air une
évidence les points animal c'est juste
bon bah y'a quelqu'un qui a lancé une
mode qui a l'air visiblement de réussir
c'est vrai d'où on n'a rien à voir là
dedans on est des restaurateurs ont fait
les choses bien
on reste ouvert je reste ouvert quoi
qu'il arrive si je finis en prison
blaine chercher c'est maintenant maxence
tentent de dialoguer pas évident
je repose la question est ce que vous
êtes tout seul chez vous notamment à
paris tout ce qu'on appelle et
haussmannien sa date du 19e siècle
on est pratiquement à l'époque de
napoléon ça remonte vraiment pour
défense un lien pourtant napoléon avait
un bonaparte c'est comme ça qu'on dit
mais voilà italien allait bien aller je
suis assez satisfait la nature c'est
quand même un truc de dingue lewis et
oman où les fleurs elle bouge pas en
principe donc du coup c'est les insectes
qui font le travail le trajet et tout
est celle ci elle a trouvé le moyen
d'exploser d'envoyer sa semence super
loin moi c'est un modèle pouvoir un jour
je leur avais dit quand on partait en
week-end il sait vraiment mais pourquoi
vous partez en week end avec papa et
c'est la première image qui est venu je
leur avais dit que d'un coup c'est un
peu comme une voiture
et si on voulait que la voiture ait tout
au bout de la route aussi longue soit
elle il fallait temps en temps on est un
peu la voiture au garage pour vérifier
que tout fonctionne
d'accueil hommes de gross ça n'a pas
l'air de vouloir bien durcir un n'est
pas gentil c'est pas la taille qui
compte 11 à janis maxi dit que des
bêtises ils te disent quoi les gens
quand ils te reconnaissent dans la rue
or henri salvador